vielen dank für die vorstellung ich
freue mich sehr heute hier sein zu
dürfen und auch profil zu repräsentieren
die institution für hochschuldidaktik an
der lmu
wir bieten jetzt den münchner
dozierenden netzwerk seit ungefähr einem
jahr oder so glaube ich es ist fast ein
jahr ein heim bei uns in unseren räumen
und ich finde sehr stark wie sich das
entwickelt hat das ist so ein symposium
überhaupt zustande kommen kann das ist
ein sehr gutes zeichen
ich wurde allerdings nicht deshalb
eingeladen war ich weil ich ein heim
oder ein dach bietet sondern oder weil
wir so nett sind bei profil sondern weil
ich in meiner funktion als elearning
koordinator der lmu eben auch etwas zu
digitalen lehrmethoden zu sagen habe und
zwar insbesondere deshalb war ich bei
profil zuständig bin für die application
mobile kurz halten moby dick
diese app selbst gäbe es nicht wenn es
gar keine lehrer lernmethoden gäbe und
deshalb ist eine vorstellung dieser app
bei einer tagung wie dieser die sich
eben um das thema interaktive
lernmethoden dreht auch tatsächlich
überaus passend es ist meiner
beobachtungen und der reinen statistik
nach nicht selbstverständlich dass sich
hochschul lehrende in einer derartigen
vielfältigkeit mit hochschuldidaktik
auseinandersetzen
auf den normalen hochschuldidaktischen
kongressen wie zum beispiel der dg hd
oder dem tag der lehre in sankt pölten
betreffe ich überaus selten tatsächlich
lehrende sondern meist wissenschaftliche
mitarbeiter von hochschuldidaktik
programm
außerdem kenne ich dieses problem
ebenfalls aus dem weit gefächerten
kurzprogramm von profil ich habe hier
mal für den diesen monat abgelichtet was
so bei uns läuft und mit diesen decken
wir zumindest einen großen teil an
dozenten der lmu ab aber eben leider
nicht den großteil
und es sind vor allem junge oder
unerfahrene dozenten die ihren weg in
die kursräume von profil finden und die
fragen die sich mir angesichts dieses
verhältnisses stellen sind benötigen
erfahrene hochschuldozenten keine
informationen zu aktualisierung von lehr
konzepten oder benötigen erfahrene
hochschuldozenten keine austausch über
weiterführende die möglichkeiten und
neue anwendungs optionen
von lehr lern methoden wollen erfahren
hochschuldozenten nicht die neuesten
didaktischen strategien kennen lernen um
mit ihrer lehre auf dem neuesten stand
zu sein und was geben sie dann die an
diejenigen weiter die gerade frisch in
die lehre einsteigen
in einer studie die meine profi kollegin
frau wege gemeinsam mit professor kranz
von der fakultät für informatik der
universität passau und andreas müller
damals noch in der tu münchen
durchgeführt hat in dieser studie trat
diesbezüglich folgendes zu tage
und dies ist der hauptgrund weshalb
hochschuldozenten selten
hochschuldidaktische maßnahmen ergreifen
und ist weder der grund faulheit noch
das interesse weshalb hochschuldozenten
sich nicht mit didaktik
auseinandersetzen
es wurde in dieser studie unter den
befragten hochschuldozenten ganz im
gegenteil sogar ein sehr reges interesse
für neue lernmethoden attestiert und es
gab außerdem ein sehr großes interesse
sowohl bei studierenden wie auch beim
hochschul dozierenden ein interesse
daran dass der wissensgewinn durch die
seminare zu nehmen sollen
aber das eben bei gleichzeitig weniger
bis gar keine kenntnis von lehr lern wir
tun und das ist grund für diese geringe
kenntnis wurde seitens der dozierenden
ein sehr spezifischer aspekt angegeben
ja und das ist ja die zeit
zeitmangel wir haben eben schon drüber
geredet fest seit man erhält die
dozenten davon ab sich neben den
lehrinhalten zusätzlich noch gedanken
über strukturen vermittlungs art in
ihren seminaren zu machen und das ist
sehr schade
gute lehre sollte nicht an zeitmangel
scheitern finden zumindest wie bei
profil also haben wir angefangen zu
überlegen wann ist denn überhaupt mal
zeit um sich mit didaktik
auseinanderzusetzen und ich gebe gerne
diese frage mal in die runde
hier sitzen ja vornehmlich
hochschuldozenten aus allen möglichen
disziplin wahlen hatten sie dann zeit
sich mit interaktiven lernmethoden
auseinanderzusetzen
in den semesterferien
in der freizeit in der u-bahn ja
ja ja absolut aber das sind ja auch so
moment das sind auch tatsächlich sachen
die wir uns überlegt haben wann haben
sie zeit sich damit auseinanderzusetzen
in paros und auf dem heimweg in meiner
freizeit ja wenn ich bereits da bin ich
dabei wenn die sitzung zu planen
vielleicht sogar wenn der dozent in der
vorbereitungsarbeit für seine nächste
seminar sitzt und brütet dann hat
derzeit falls ein bis dahin noch nicht
in profil kurs war ja und schon ideen
hat oder auf einem anderen weg
didaktische vorkenntnisse erworben hat
ja wie kann man solchen leuten helfen
wir müssen jetzt darüber ihre arbeit
sitzen da das seminar vorhalten jetzt
sei aber nicht die möglichkeit witziges
detail ist auch in genannter studie von
vorher von 2012 wurde ebenfalls gefragt
was und produzierende als auch
studierende eigentlich von der lehr-
oder von lehr- oder lerninhalten während
der serie nase zu ablenkt das war so
eine weitere frage der studie
und da kann ich gleich wieder fragen was
da wohl auf platz eins lag aber ich
nehme an dass diese ablenkungs faktor
mittlerweile noch wesentlich gewachsen
ist ja so in den letzten fünf jahren das
ist jetzt noch weiter nummer eins
geworden ist mit abstand zu platz zwei
ja das wäre dann quasi so fc bayern kann
man nicht mehr sagen
aber sagen wir mal ja so ungefähr im
fußball weit vorne ehemals fc bayern und
alle anderen trottel irgendwie hinterher
was ist abwendung facto noch mal eins in
seminaren bei dozierende wie auch
studierende
absolut ja kommt gleich jetzt erstes
handy smartphone das ist ablenkungs
faktor nummer eins und das auch weil es
eben so viele möglichkeiten der
einsatzmöglichkeit geht man kann soviel
damit machen
unter anderem deshalb nehme das
medienwissenschaftler auch push medium
weil es sich wie ihr tönen popper
nachrichten usw permanent die
aufmerksamkeit seiner user pusht und die
damit zum beispiel das seminar ablenkt
was tun die user mit dem smartphone
während des seminars laut studie setzt
sich das folgendermaßen zusammen 61
prozent schauen ihre e mails nach 52
prozent sind in sozialen netzwerken
unterwegs
fast genauso viele nämlich 51 prozent
lesen die aktuelle nachrichten
und 49 prozent informieren sich über das
wetter nun sagt alles an der user
während eines seminars übrigens auch
dozenten ich habe das mal bei mir
überprüft ich bin ja auch als dozent
tätig wie gesagt wurde in der
theaterwissenschaft zu methoden in der
theaterwissenschaft hören wir aber dann
morgen professor östen hier vorne sitzt
da liegt gar nicht weiter darauf
eingehen dass wird er super machen
also ich hab das mal für mich selber
überprüft und festgestellt kurz vor
seminarbeginn gehe ich tatsächlich noch
mal all diese anwendungen durch dem
aufgelistet worden sind weil eventuell
könnten darunter tatsächlich
informationen seien ich benötige für das
seminar ja beispielsweise
unwetterwarnungen oder terroristen
warnung oder sowas ja auf einmal könnte
es ist unheimlich wichtig sagte ist eine
neue erkenntnis die gerade im
nachrichten erschienen sind
deswegen gehe ich da tatsächlich durch
was ist alles da ja so ein handy lexikon
quasi für mich wenn ich das alles eben
diese beiden faktoren auf einen
gemeinsamen nenner herunter brechen
müsste dann könnte man sagen mit dem
smartphone wird eben getan wozu es
gedacht das ist werden informationen wie
es wird vielleicht sogar wissen
gesammelt und auch ausgetauscht und das
relativ schnell und ohne großen aufwand
sowie die zu nahezu jeder und jederzeit
und allerorts und prinzipiell sprechen
wir an dieser stelle dann eben schon von
mobile learning im sinne der
informatiker robert und schwabe damit
jetzt schönes zitat nachdem umfasst
mobile learning alles lernen mit mobilen
endgeräten mit zunehmender erfahrung
entdecken forscherinnen und
praktikerinnen das andere formate des
lernens das potenzial der
mobiltechnologie deutlich besser nutzen
es kommt dabei mehr auf die mobilität
des nutzers an
also auf eine konkrete unterstützung
technologie da wo sich als
medienwissenschaftler nicht als
informatiker und ein bisschen eingrenzen
was gilt frohberg und schwabe
ansprechendes digital mobile learning da
ist der medienwissenschaft mir ganz
genau denn wie man in dem wirklich sehr
guten aufsatzband von martin stingl hin
und matthias thiele zu portable media
nachlesen kann gibt es ebenfalls mobile
medien ohne den faktor gerät zu sein
oder überhaupt digital zu sein
bücher beispielsweise das buch ist eines
der ersten mobilen medien die wunderbar
zum lernen herangezogen werden können
ich habe noch mit büchern gelernt zum
beispiel bücher haben wir alle bereits
immobilien lernen benutzt und ich glaube
sie werden auch heute noch benutzt ja
bin ich
der festen überzeugung ich hab gerade
text 1 getrennt dafür meine seminare
mobiles lernen heißt nämlich nichts
anderes als dass ich meine lern und den
siegel über den mitnehmen können weil
sie eben transportabel sind und ich
deshalb wiederum mobile bin mit einem
fest installierten pc wäre mobiles
lernen zb sehr viel schwerer laptop
eignet sich und er so und an dem punkt
mit diesen gedanken exkurs hatten wir
bei profil an ein eine eingebung und bei
allen gelegenheiten an den dozierenden
zeit haben all die zeit punkte die sich
auch zuvor genannt haben ja in genau
diesem moment in der u-bahn oder halt
kurzfristig über den seminarunterlagen
da hat jeder so zieren sein smartphone
dabei und aus der studie wissen wir dass
smartphones dazu dienen informationen zu
vermitteln
wow ja kommen zwei dinge zusammen kann
man auf diesem weg dozierenden ein hilfs
tool an die hand geben um ihnen die
infos über lernmethoden zu kommunizieren
die sie so gerne haben möchten und das
geht natürlich ich bin jetzt kein fan
davon die gesamte entwicklungsgeschichte
dieser app mobil dix vorzutragen ich
denke auch dass sie das alles überhaupt
gar nicht an dieser stelle interessiert
das können sie viel besser nachlesen und
dem artikel den ich mit meiner kollegin
format geschrieben habe der steht online
zum freien download bereit in der
zeitschrift die hochschullehre die
übrigens wirklich sehr genau sind mit
ihrem peer review verfahren das ist
schon fast wie bei amerikanischen
zeitschriften oder ist es fast genauso
schwer reinzukommen
in diese hochschule zeitschrift wie für
die spd in den bundestag
ganz aktuell meinem vortrag
egal also der titel des artikels lautet
wenn der prophet nicht zum berg kommen
kann und sie können den link entweder
direkt googeln oder aber entweder auf
der profil website unter publikationen
oder über meine private website unter
online publikation finden so viel dazu
ich möchte diese knappe halbe stunde
statt das herunterbeten es dieser
historie viel lieber im übergeordneten
sinne des symposiums dafür nutzen zu
erläutern wie wir uns gedacht haben dass
die app mobil dix helfen kann und zu
diesem zweck gehe ich nun im folgenden
demnach auf die funktionsweise den
nutzen sowie die einsatzmöglichkeiten
von moby dick sein
bevor ich am ende einen kurzen ausblick
in die zukunft wagen und dass genau
dieser rein
und deshalb starte ich auch mit der
funktion der funktionsweise was ist mir
wichtig und wie funktioniert ist
ausgehend vom problem dass viele
hochschule dutzende geringe kenntnisse
von lehr lernmethoden besitzen aber sich
aus zeitmangel nicht darüber informieren
steht man vor dem problem dass der
prophet eben nicht zum berg kommen kann
deshalb heißt ja auch der online artikel
so in welcher form bringt man also den
berg an didaktischen methoden zum
dozenten bzw auf dessen smartphone
klasse das war uns auch sofort klar und
dann waren sie schnell klar dass wir
dennoch eine webbasierte version
benötigen die am pc genutzt werden kann
schließlich sollen doch die möglichkeit
haben dort ihre eigenen methoden mit
anderen zu teilen und das schreiben
solche methoden beziehungsweise kurzer
text ist am pc dann doch wesentlich
einfacher als ein smartphone
die meisten mobile user greifen übrigens
tatsächlich über ihren pc auf die
anwendung zu ich auch weil ich sie
meistens dazu nutze wenn ich dabei bin
eine seminare sitzung neu zu konzipieren
und das mache ich auch meistens am pc
manchmal habe ich auf das smartphone
dann nebenbei auf und haben verschiedene
methoden auf einmal nehmen guckt welche
besser sein könnte also es existieren
übrigens auch beide versionen bereits
und die sind über das jeweilige nutzer
profil des users miteinander
synchronisiert was schlicht bedeutet was
ich in der app auf meinem handy
anstelle kann ich ebenso eine app auf
meinem pc einsehen wenn ich mit
demselben nutzerprofil eingeloggt bin
und das wird übrigens immer verwechselt
es gibt apps nicht ausschließlich für
das handy sondern auch für desktop pcs
werde mich richtig in szene gab es dazu
erst für den personal computer und
danach jeweils bringt diese app die wir
entwickelt haben egal auf welchem gerät
sie genutzt wird vordergründig eine
wesentliche leistung sie stellt eine
datenbank von interaktiven leer
lernmethoden bereit die permanent
abgerufen werden kann die einzigen
voraussetzungen dafür sie über nutzen zu
können sind dass man smartphone besitzer
ist um nutzer konto angelegt hat und die
app installiert hat die app selbst steht
sowohl in google places auch im app
store bereit und ist im übrigen
kostenfrei das war's mehr braucht man
nicht auf dem smartphone benötigen sie
nicht mal nach einmalige institution
internetzugriff denn auf die datenbank
kann auch ohne netz zugegriffen werden
die datenbank aktualisiert sich
automatisch
als ich dann das nächste mal per
internet via smartphone darauf zugreifen
also gut strom sollte man schon haben
das ist allerdings die voraussetzung
wenn sie mobile pc über einen web
browser nutzen benötigen sie sogar nur
dass nutzer konto und strom
sie melden sich über eine maske mit
nutzernamen und einem passwort an dass
musik kennen und nachdem sie der admin
freigeschaltet hat das bin ich
danach haben sie sofortigen zugriff auf
die interaktive datenbank anleger
lernmethoden und jetzt denken viele die
hier sind okay ja es gibt viele websites
im netz die lehrmethoden versammeln und
da muss ich mich nicht immer extra
anmelden das stimmt prinzipiell ja aber
es sind die zahlreichen zusatzfunktionen
von moby dick sie eine sinnvolle
ergänzung der datenbank darstellen und
damit sind wir auch schon bei meinem
zweiten punkt dem nutzen von moby dick
sticks kann nämlich viel mehr
da jedoch die bindung die bedienung sehr
einfach ist wird es meistens gar nicht
auf abermals vergleich die meisten frei
zugänglichen websites die lehrer
lernmethoden sammeln tun dies in form
eines pdfs also als katalog quasi und
das ist nicht besonders nutzerfreundlich
diese pdf müssen sie dann nämlich
blättern blättern blättern scrollen
scrollen sro bisschen nach ende der
suche endlich gefunden haben was sie
tatsächlich benötigen
was für ihre individuelle seminar
situation passt oder sie wenn gar nicht
fündig und wie ist dieses problem zu
lösen und das anwendungsorientiert
denken das stichwort pdf katalog bietet
dementsprechend wenig optionen und
passgenau das zu liefern was sie in
ihrem speziellen fall für ihr seminar
suchen wie bereits festgestellt viel
mehr strukturiert das pdf vor wie sie zu
suchen haben
also müssen die suchparameter erweitert
werden schließlich kennen sie ihre
suchparameter selbst am besten unterwegs
bietet hierfür alle denkbaren
auswahlmöglichkeiten an
ich nehme jetzt mal wiederum mich als
wissenschafts prozent nur als
fallbeispiel aber ich versuche das ab
sagt die möglichst alt und damit alle
mitkommen
oftmals ist es in der vorbereitung auf
ein seminar so dass die im besten fall
die inhalte kennen die sie in einer
sitzung vermitteln wollen sie wissen
zudem meistens wie viele teilnehmerinnen
in der jeweiligen sitzung idealerweise
anwesend sein sollten
aber ich kann zumindest abschätzen wie
viele studierende tatsächlich anwesend
sein
da kann immer so garten 30 sind es
maximal 15 kommen und das sind schon mal
zwei faktoren die meine suche dann
eingrenzen
ich persönlich gebe eben meistens
seminare für 30 teilnehmerinnen dann
fallen bereits für mich alle leer
lernmethoden weg die nur für eine
gruppengröße von sagen wir 15 personen
geeignet sind und ich benötige auch
jetzt nicht unbedingt eine methode für
200 personen bei musik kann ich genau
danach filter nicht demonstriert das
jetzt mal kurz dann muss ich jetzt mal
hier rausgehen ich hab es hoffentlich
noch ich habe es hoffentlich noch offen
wunderbar also ich will jetzt mal die
erweiterte suchfunktion aus da habe ich
[Musik]
hier diverse parameter und das habe ich
mir ausgesucht damit ist das klappt ja
ja genau ich nehme jetzt mal eine
gruppengröße maximum und gäbe da meine
30 leute ein und man sieht dann dass
sich die zahl der methoden drastisch
reduziert ja diese methoden sind für bis
zu 30 personen geeignet
ich kann auch die freitextsuche nutzen
ja dann mache ich das nur ich den super
meter weg sagen wir mal ich halte das
referate abhalten weil die in den
prüfungsordnungen festgeschrieben sind
ich muss separat abhalten lassen in
meinem seminar aber permanent immer die
normale referats struktur ist mir zu
langweilig und vielleicht auch den
studierenden also dann gebe ich einfach
ein fahrrad ein und erhalte immerhin 12
34 methoden die für referate geeignet
sind oder ich möchte beispielsweise mal
was anderes machen als
[Musik]
moment
ja ich mache das jetzt bloß einzeln
damit man es immer der letzte nicht
unübersichtlich wird oder ich möchte mal
was anderes machen als zum beispiel
immer mit dem whiteboard zu arbeiten
dann kann ich mal gucken beispielsweise
was habe ich zu hause scheuch legen
scheint recht gehen die küche wie ich
habe wo ich halt auch immer arbeite und
finde eine eieruhr habe ich das frische
eier perfekt das ist ja ich vorher
eingestellt dass es nicht funktioniert
die gruppengröße moment das geht schon
material das soll das war mit theo ton
spielt sich das material genau uhr und
dann schaue ich mir mal beispielsweise
an
ja genau das wollte ich immer machen
eine methode reinschauen powernapping
sack da sehen wir nicht mal ein katalog
also ist immer relativ ähnlich aufgebaut
bei moby dick wir haben immer eine falls
ich es eh schon weiß wie die methode
funktioniert und mich nur kurz daran
erinnern will
ein bild das mich kurz daran erinnert ja
ja okay so kann es funktionieren ja wir
haben die alternativ namen alles für die
freitextsuche halt werden hier wie sie
abläuft in dem fall sie kündigen den
lernenden nach einem abschnitt oder
anstrengenden an hey einheit an dass die
zeit für eine power napping geben damit
sie sich wieder erholen und fit werden
können also sollen die köpfe auf den
tisch gelegt werden und aus gut werden
nach zwei minuten klingelt ein lauter
und schriller wecker kann auch ein
lauter und angenehmer becker sein das je
nach belieben
es gibt beispiele es gibt tipps von den
profis
es gibt das kommentarfeld das hat ist da
jetzt zum beispiel nicht genutzt wurden
moment aber
nur bei feedback bombe zum beispiel ist
das kommentarfeld genutzt worden wenn
ich mich richtig und sind genau da ist
dann gleich vor hat kommentiert anonym
feedback zeitlich eingrenzen sinnvoller
tipp wahrscheinlich steht aber glaube
ich auch oben in der beschreibung
beziehungsweise ist durch diese methode
auch einfach einschränkt radio es
klingelt an dem punkt wo das feedback
enden soll
gut zu der kategorie phase genau hier wo
kann ich auch noch als letztes hier
umsieht methode zu beschreiben weil ich
mit dem punkt nämlich zu unserem in
unserem powerpoint vortrag am besten zum
letzten punkt übergehen kann
zu den einsatzmöglichkeiten moby dick
orientiert sich an einem schema nämlich
dass herangezogen werden kann
im seminar sitzungen oder vorlesungen
eigentlich lehrveranstaltungen jedweder
art für eine möglichst erfolgreiche
wissensvermittlung zu strukturieren das
sogenannte aviva schäme da ist es bei
profil empfehlen wir das vor allem
unseren an anwärterin auf die tutow plus
ausbildung sind ja ein paar hier die die
tudors ausbildung absolviert haben und
absolvieren das aviva stemann lässt sich
in fünf bis sechs phasen gliedern wie
man sich denken kann stehen die
einzelbuchstaben dabei für jeweils einer
der fünf hauptphase dafür ausrichten ich
hab hier auswerten geschrieben dass es
ein tippfehler vorwissen aktivieren ii
informieren v verarbeiten und auswerten
schnell erkennt der geschulte blick des
dozenten das sind alles bestandteile die
in einer normalen lehrveranstaltung
nicht fehlen sollten vor der phase des
ausrichtenden erfolgt meist noch die
schaffung einer angenehmen
lernatmosphäre sei es durch bestimmte
sitz konstellation oder schlicht eine
begrüßung durch den dozierenden
in der ausrichtung phase wird auf das
thema der sitzung eingestimmt
anschließend wird das vorwissen der
teilnehmerinnen aktiviert danach werden
sie über die neuen fakten theorien etc
informiert sie die werden dann
schließlich verarbeitet so dass sie im
gedächtnis bleiben und somit zu neuem
wissen werden auch die überprüfung der
anwendbarkeit des neuen wissens erfolgt
hier
und zum abschluss wird noch ausgewertet
was hängen geblieben ist und es wird ein
feedback eingeholt die phasen sind jetzt
nicht so strikt einzuhalten es ist
beispielsweise denkbar informieren und
verarbeiteten verarbeiten beliebig oft
wiederholen je nach wunsch so dass
eventueller fifa 10 herauskommt oder
sowas
hier wird orientiert sich mobil ticks
genau an diesen phasen des aviva chemie
wie sicher wie sie wahrscheinlich wissen
oder sich zumindest denken können ist
nämlich jede leer lernmethode für jede
er ist eben nicht jede der lernmethode
für jede phase geeignet stellen wir
beispielsweise stehen uns vor ein
kurzvortrag diskutierenden am ende einer
dreistündigen sitzung dann können wir
uns denken dass die wenigsten studenten
überhaupt noch aufnahmefähig sind ebenso
wenig effekt hat eine feedback methode
zur gesamten sitzung die am anfang der
sitzung stattfindet es seine sie zur
letzten sitzung aber dann liegt da
meistens eine woche dazwischen ich weiß
nicht wie effizient das wäre jede
methode lässt sich zumindest einer
oftmals aber auch mehreren phasen des
aviva schemas zuordnen wenn ich nun
meine seminare sitzung sinnvollerweise
nach dem aviva schema strukturiere dann
kann ich zielgenau bei moby dick nach
methoden suchen die sich genau in diesen
phasen einsetzen lassen
das aviva schema kennt auch noch eine
feindliche rung der einzelnen phasen in
unter phasen die sich ebenfalls als
suchparameter mobilex wiederfinden aber
das würde jetzt als zu weit führen damit
würden wir uns ein detaillierter in
details verlieren
ich möchte lieber ganz am ende noch ein
paar gedanken zum einsatz der app und
damit auch zu lehrmethoden allgemein
loswerden und zwar betone ich gerne dass
derlei methoden definitiv helfen seminar
sitzungen zu optimieren
aus eigener erfahrung wenn sie richtig
ausgewählt und eingeführt werden
allerdings und lehrmethoden kein
allheilmittel nur weil ich die einsätze
garantiert dass nicht dass meine
seminare automatische effizienter werden
auch mit diesen methoden muss der
richtige umgang gefunden werden oftmals
muss methoden seines seinen bedürfnissen
oder den rahmenbedingung
anpassen man muss kreativ wird ihnen
umgehen auf einen stuhlkreis zu bestehen
ohne stühle zu haben führt meist zu
keinem ziel und dann ist die einführung
der methode ebenso entscheidend wie eine
gute erklärung
ansonsten nehmen die teilnehmer das
darauf fallen überhaupt nicht ernst ich
hab mal zum ich hab meinen beispiel
mitgebracht aus einem erklärungsversuch
zu unserem wahlsystem um zu zeigen wie
man eher schlecht in eine methode
einsteigt und zwar habe ich
glücklicherweise diesmal per briefwahl
gewählt glücklicherweise aber sonst
hätte ich dieses wahnsinnig tolle
beispiel nicht gefunden und zwar ist es
der erklärung zettel wie man briefwahl
in der bundesrepublik korrekt angeht der
sogenannte wegweiser zur briefwahl
der lag den wahlunterlagen bei und da
liest man als ersten schritt und das
eigentlich der entscheidenden nämlich
wie man wählt und da liest man
stimmzettel persönlich an kreuzen sie am
zwei stimmen erststimme links zwei
stimmrechts
das habe ich erst gelesen nachdem ich
schon zweimal links gewählt hatte aber
okay beim nächsten mal weiß ich bescheid
übrigens und das glaube ich erklärt dann
aber auch das wahlergebnis wenn sie das
ändern wird es beim nächsten mal nicht
so rechtslastig seien aber abseits des
spaßes gilt es tatsächlich zu
berücksichtigen dass auch der umgang mit
lehr lernmethoden geübt sein will
da gehört erfahrung und so manches
experiment dazu und dann kommen wir halt
zum blick in die zukunft und weil das so
ist wagen wir bei profil auch den
nächsten experimentellen vorstoß da
mobile mittlerweile bereits seit 2003
zehn überaus erfolgreich ist und sogar
den usa auf ein paar smartphones
installiert wurde sie haben vielleicht
gesehen man kann auch auf englisch und
bei paar methoden schon auf französisch
umswitchen wir wollen weitere
vergleichbare apps entwickeln zuerst
soll ist aber ein interface update für
mobiles geben schöner userfreundlichen
praktikabler und danach erscheint dann
hoffentlich
da erscheint dann die app quick ewald
der systematische aufbau dabei wird
überwiegend publiques entsprechen die
methoden die darin zu finden sein werden
sind allerdings evaluations methoden die
schnell und simpel durchzuführen sind
deswegen clique war und geplant außerdem
mit elektrik und tutor x2 weitere apps
mit methoden speziell für tutorinnen und
tutoren beziehungsweise für elia und e
learning methoden und mit diesen drei
apps stehen daneben die drei eckpfeiler
einer guten lehre und lehrende hätten
über die apps eine grundversorgung
inspiration für ihre lehre
damit sie alle hier auch zumindest
inspiriert werden durfte ich auch noch
was mitbringen meine kollegin hat es
gepackt wie bei uns für die
zertifizierung zuständig ist und in die
zeit gefunden hat solche typen zu packen
die finden sie vorne im tackling raum
denn je das geht in hetlingen
wir nehmen den catering und dort finden
sie so wundertüten die sie mitnehmen
dürfen solange der vorrat reicht was
auch immer drin ich weiß auch nicht ich
habe sie nur transportieren ich fühle
verschiedene sachen auf jeden fall und
es raschelt auch und ich darf auf jeden
fall nochmals betonen wie sehr es mich
freut dass die alle hier so ein großes
interesse an didaktisch ausgereifter
lehre haben und ich bin gespannt auf die
vorträge und den input und wünsche uns
allen eine spannende tagung vielen dank